there are other ways to save lives so
much you don't know
hey guys I'm Lucy and I'm tomorrow and
we've been see dr. strange because for
some strange reason it's coming out in
the UK earlier yeah and in America so we
thought we do yes we appreciate that a
lot so we can do some spoiler free chat
about it and whether it's worth your
time and yes it's a very good very good
um but let's let's start by talking
about Benedict Cumberbatch I mean we
know him as Sherlock yeah as that's
pretty much the only thing I know how
much that's it and now you will know him
as dr. strange because as I said in my
review which can read on gamespot com
he's he's eyes perfect for Doctor
Strange Stephen strange as Robert Downey
jr. was for Tony Stark like I I said it
in my review a few months from now
you're not going to be able to separate
the two people the two characters you
know how robert downey jr. is everywhere
and people are like oh look it's Tony
Stark I feel like it's gonna be very
similar for Benedict Cumberbatch I
thought he was perfect well cuz he's got
these got the chops of being able to
play the eccentric genius as we seen in
Sherlock and he does that very well as
Stephen strange who was a you know a
very very intelligent neuroscientist
yeah he has a photographic memory and
you know so he's very much living the
man of science role mm-hmm at the very
beginning yeah he liked lucky said
Sherlock is the perfect touchstone for
him he can be because like Tony Stark
Stephen strange is ego driven he's
arrogant he thinks he's better than
everyone else he thinks he's the
smartest man in every room but i like i
like the fact that although he starts
off he's there's a knock to his
character obviously and it's a familiar
it's the same one that they used for
Tony Stark and a lot of the other origin
stories within the MCU they stick pretty
close to it and he goes through you know
changes and he realizes that he doesn't
he's not the smartest person in the
world he goes and meets the ancient one
pay played by Tilda Swinton and it kind
of goes through gods were a journey
which lets Benedict Cumberbatch kind of
put his acting talents to use in a good
way you get some variety from him you
get to see him means
then you can see him being like utterly
bewildered by everything happening
around him because he's just suddenly
thrust into this world of magic when
he's used to science and yeah you get a
nice like variety of acting camera I
thought was really well done I thought
he was great in there and yeah thumbs up
for me on Benedict Cumberbatch what
stuck out for me is that I think the
movie has way more of its own visual
identity than perhaps any of the other
Marvel yeah definitely if it makes
watching it's it's like it doesn't have
a lot of like color and that kind of
stuff it's not trying to overwhelm me a
lot of people have described it as
psychedelic but it is psychedelic in a
way that it is doing trippy things but
it's not psychedelic as in like hey
check out these weird colors flashing by
but it does have its own identity in
that it's just trying to break your
brain as much as possible it's like
taking buildings and interning mob
saying that scene from inception it's
very I mean like when that when that
moment comes in you think ok I've seen
this in the inception and then it just
sort of adds in elements of maybe like
the matrix yeah puts in a few
kaleidoscopes some really weird trippy
things in yeah and it does a really good
job because at that time you're sort of
SAT with Stephen because you're like oh
you know it's a movie how they gonna
possibly show just how strange and how
much we don't know about the world and
then there has this incredible sequence
that you do kind of sit there and go
okay that was pretty cool yeah it's it's
a fairly sequence fairly on in the movie
and it just it's kind of overwhelms you
with weird and crazy stuff to kind of
just it needs to introduce magic to you
and it just does it by just dropping a
bucket of it over your head and by the
end of it you're like this is amazing
but yeah it does have its own unique
visual identity I feel like it makes the
rest of the Marvel movies look quite
plain in terms of Iron Man and Captain
America they have these kind of like
themes and aesthetics but nothing like
outlandish and this is the most
memorable visually model may be alert
you like and also when it comes to the
fight sequences in the action sequences
they do some really clever stuff that
we're not going to go into too much but
like that ending five secrets for me was
you're incredible and I could only
imagine that
rector's headaches today again that
production going because it was
incredible most of the action sequences
I mean it's very matrix e it's very
Crouching Tiger it reminded me quite a
lot of avatar the last airbender which
is its popular but not a lot of people
here watch it but like the way that in
that they use the elements and they're
summoning them and moving around being
very like kinetic moving around and
using like bring up water to block the
enemies it's quite similar except
they're kind of reshaping reality around
the fight it's just I just I said it was
as exhausting to watch as it was
thrilling and it really is you're
keeping track of so many people as how
many times and up his down down is up
and they're falling through things and
you're like it's brilliant by the same
time you like need a break now it's but
yeah I loved it so in previous Marvel
movies we've had you know the incredible
technologies of Tony Stark the science
of Man Hulk we've had as God's we've had
other worlds you've got you know and I
scouting to the galaxy does this movie
do a good job of sort of adding
mysticism to what seems like an already
quite full pot I think it does it does
and I think it does it in a really good
luck way it sits I won't go into too
much details but there's a kind of a one
line that is mentioned fairly early on
in the movie that kind of places
mysticism into the Marvel Universe and
presents it as something that's always
been there but you just never have
noticed it it's been there it's
happening while everything else in the
MCU is happening you just didn't realize
it's kind of like that line where it's
like if you do everything right they
won't be show you to yeah yeah I mean it
feels like it I thought it was really
clever it's like they opened the door
and said while you were looking that way
this stuff was happening over here and I
think it's really they needed to bring
mysticism into it because they needed an
element of mysticism that's a threat
that's much larger than flying
supercomputer Tin Man can deal with and
even like Hulk can deal with they need
someone who's a little more out there
yeah that's where Stephen strange comes
in and you know there's probably some
more like magical heroes that they're
going to try and slide in but I think
it's good it's a new texture to it I'm
one of those people that love the Marvel
movies but I'm starting to get bogged
down in the
fighting and the kind of the political
stuff and everyone hates each other sort
of so the fact that they have this
separate universe within the universe
that is just completely distinct for it
is really exciting for me they can tell
unique stories that don't have to feed
back into what iron man feels about
Captain America on this day yeah I think
it's really successful and bringing
mysticism to it and it's excited and
rejuvenate my love of the MCU now and of
course you can't really talk about
Marvel movies and out sort of the
comedic side the comedic chops that all
of the actors bring to it so is um well
we've both seen it yeah it's a very
funny movie but it's it's funny in that
Marvel way it's not overwhelming funny
their mother like great are really using
humor to at the right moment and not
kind of dwelling on it too much they use
it in this to kind of after all the
crazy topsy-turvy action happens they'll
give you a couple of jokes us just to
kind of like level you out a bit I kind
of you know ease the pace off he goes
your little breathing room will be like
yeah quit or a line or throw away yeah
and everyone has something funny to say
or I dropped a joke in there even Mads
Mikkelsen which official yeah I don't
see him as a comedic actor but yeah lays
it in a very deadpan way yeah he's I
mean he's it's done in a way that he
doesn't tell he doesn't realize he's
being funny that's the point of the joke
we won't explain it again but like it's
because of that it's perfect he just
like stares directly into the camera and
says a line that's hilarious and doesn't
realize that it's a joke and similarly
obviously Stevens quiet he's very much
Tony Stark is vitamin E he's dropping
some you know quips in here and there is
being sharp witted and is a kind of
partner or he's not a real partner right
now sex yeah she's quite like more of
like a you know physical comedy club
thing she's always like jumping around
and being scared that stuff she's under
used in a movie shame but I would like
to see him oh because it's rachel
mcadams yeah I quite like it I like the
way that their relationship is kind of
like quite subtly and nuanced because it
feels like you're not joining them at
the beginning of their relationship it's
already happened yeah and so you're
learning about it after the fact and
they do in a very very small away um
Benedict one very confusing name because
here he plays a character Benedict Wong
is his real name yeah he
a character called Wang was confusing
because they were strangers played by
Benedict Cumberbatch so I wrote that in
my review and everyone was like you
understand any of the names of what's
happening here but like I was like no
trust me who works but he's quite funny
he's a very like stoic librarian yeah
I'm obviously one goes on to become
Stephen strange is Butler type kind of
like faithful assistant but yeah his
Alfred but like he is just stoic and
Stephen strange his job is just to make
him laugh at some point and the he uses
like cultural touchstones and I love
that they use like modern cultural
touchstones as part of their comedy
because it could just like it's just
funny and kind of like and it grounds
the the universe in kind of a modern
real world as well which is quite
exciting I know that so I understood
diamond even Tilda Swinton is funny yes
geez I'm very annoyed she first Lee
she's an unbelievable badass like her
fight sequences are probably some of the
best like she's got the best
hand-to-hand sequences and but yeah her
jokes are quite good because she's
channeling the audience like when she's
giving showing you these weird things
she knows that Stephen strange is weird
feeling weird about it and out of his
depth and because you relate with
Stephen strange you will also have the
same response when she drops her joke or
a one-liner amazing lady doc strange is
super good you should go see it make
sure you stay through credit sequence it
is very good under the post-credit
sequence as well it wasn't in our
screening so we have no idea what that
is but mid-credits is very very good so
to check out tomorrow's review ahead of
a gamespot com we'll see you next time
fine
you